hey youtubers is Charlie so my friends
from geek and sundry are building a
guidebook from final fantasy realm
reborn in real life so I wanted to do
another bonus lore video that just
talked a little bit about other
legendary weapons in the game as well as
put it into perspective with the rest of
the Final Fantasy series so in the
episode they talked a little bit about
why the guide bowl is so much cooler
than you know 99% of all the other
weapons it's legendary anyone who's
played Wow or really any MMO for that
matter knows legendary items appear like
once or twice on a server with a few
exceptions there are craftable
Legendary's you know regular items that
you just are able to add boss drops and
other quest items too until you
eventually crafted two legendary status
I think my wow guild had to grind fire
lands on heroic for a month just to get
our Buchan his dragon wrath staff the
fun kind of wore off after the first few
weeks but look how shiny in realm reborn
the guy bug is one of 9 relic items that
you obtain after an epic boss grind in a
bunch of other quest completions the
star quest is actually called relic
reborn and each relic is specific to
each job so here they are in no
particular order the artemis bow for the
bard the bravura for the warrior the
curtana and holy shield for the paladin
the guy bulk for the dragoon of course
the Omni Lex for the scholar thus far I
for the monk the stardust rod for the
Black Mage the veil of we you for the
summoner and the thyristor the white
mage you could write an entire book for
what it takes to obtain each of these
weapons but generally once you craft
them once you get that legendary it is
the best weapon in the game right now in
realm reborn you know each of those
relic items is the ultimate for each of
those jobs but there's always the
promise of a new expansion and the new
tier of items in their new video Nika
actually talked to one of the GM's from
Square Enix about the dragons
specifically you know just because they
Forge the guide book in real life
dragoons are historically famous for
fighting dragons but they're featured in
all of the Final Fantasy games at least
since Final Fantasy 2 sometimes they're
just mentioned in passing or they're
just a reference or they're just used as
a clothing item Final Fantasy 4 on Super
Nintendo was actually my introduction my
personal introduction to dragoons
and the series in general for that
matter
in that game Kane was the only Dragoon
and he was more of a foil for you as the
protagonist but in each iteration of the
game the guy Bowl was their signature
weapon it looks like a pike or you know
pull arm just because traditionally they
fought dragons so you can't get in
really close like you would with a sword
I totally applaud the creators of all
the different Final Fantasy games for
keeping the character traits consistent
across 30 plus years of the game
franchise that's better continuity than
the x-men franchise right now so realm
reborn actually incorporates a lot of
the lore and backstory for the dragoons
that's built up since that second Final
Fantasy game so if you have played
different versions of the game you know
a lot of the character traits as well as
items will look very familiar this
current version of the game also pays a
lot of homage to the lore of the Dragoon
characters you encounter most of them
have the surname high wit just because
across the franchise then all the
dragoons flow from cane high wind and
his family they built a lot of that
lured into the original you know Final
Fantasy 2 game when they introduced the
character you know so JRPGs aren't just
cool now they've always been that cool
that's why you see a lot of story teams
created when big western games like Halo
or other you know modern Western RPGs
are in development people in America
learned from Japanese game makers how
important story and lore was it started
to integrate it into new games that's
why the best games always have the best
stories so if you look at the guy bald
the geek and sundry built you know
Whitney Costanza right next to it yeah
she's not a giant but that actually is a
one-to-one scale that's what it would be
like in real life so if you were using a
polearm on Game of Thrones or any other
medieval series it would be that same
size they got a person to test it out
he's actually part of the armored combat
league they're like a sports league that
LARP and uses real-life armor and
weapons to do tourney sports so all the
stuff you see them wearing and using is
stuff you would see on like a medieval
battlefield they got to stab a lot of
stuff and even tried to replicate that
Dragoon jump attack you have to remember
though that real-life physics kind of
sucks just because you're carrying like
an extra hundred pounds of weight so
it'll be like strapping cinder blocks
under your feet and trying to slam dunk
a basketball if you can do that you are
probably making millions of dollars in
the NBA right now in general though my
other favorite class to play in final
fantasy games is Black Mage you know yes
they're super cool to watch but from a
practical standpoint if you can learn to
deal with being a squishy
where you get way more powerful attacks
so you're one of the best dps classes
unless you're fighting someone with high
magic resist yeah then you're just
squishy but I feel like magic dps is way
more useful later in the game or
especially if you're trying to so low
level these should run into with MMOs in
general is class tuning so as you start
maxing out your gear all the classes
start to become equally useful in raid
so I also actually wanted to include a
little update on Final Fantasy 15 that's
like the next numbered sequel in the
series although not all of them are
direct sequels to the games that came
before them so the most recent Final
Fantasy game they've released is
lightning returns and yes it's pretty
cool but Final Fantasy 15 has actually
been in development since 2006 or before
2006 they actually showed footage of it
at e3 in 2006 the reason that takes so
long to release a new numbered sequel
and the franchise is because they
basically change everything about the
game so much with each new iteration and
remember the footage we have is from
2006 and think about how much games have
changed just in the way they look from
2006 to now so they've actually had to
redesign the game several times along
the way
there isn't an official release date
other than what they've said you know
2015 you know with fingers crossed
in keeping with recent tradition the
game actually jumps to a much different
time period you know much more modern
this time like the differences between
Final Fantasy 8 and Final Fantasy 9 you
know one is super techy and the other is
super steampunky the last official
update we got from Square Enix was in
February and they said the game was you
know very far along in development which
is kind of vague but I'm expecting you
know November December of 2015
unless we get to e3 next year and they
have nothing in which case it's probably
gonna be forever games take way longer
to make the movie so don't be surprised
if it takes longer to finish so in
related news I'm actually gonna be doing
a couple more bonus lore videos over the
next couple of weeks be sure to
subscribe to get everything feel free to
leave me suggestions for other games if
you really want me to do like a lore or
a weapon video for one of those but I'm
also eventually gonna probably move
these videos to my gaming channel later
this summer so you'll see them on at
Charlie's drain so I'll just keep doing
them so right now click here to watch
geek and sundry make that guy Bullock in
real life is actually really really cool
and click here to get my
Scrolls lore video thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight high
fives